- [Voiceover] Let's see if
we can now give ourselves
a more tangible understanding of what's on
the new SAT and how it might be different
than SATs of the past.
So right over here I
have a bullet point list
of kind of the major features,
the defining features of the new SAT,
and starting up here are relevant words
in context.
And there's two important parts
to that, relevant, and context.
And when we're talking
about relevant words,
these are words that you will actually see
when you go to college,
or that you will use
in your working life.
People sometimes say something like,
"Hey, that's an SAT word."
Sometimes referring to a word that, maybe,
it's just a hard word
that is not so practical.
What's different about the new SAT,
is that they're going
to be relevant words,
and not just relevant words in a vacuum,
they're going to be in a context,
in a situation where you might be
editing a passage or reading something,
so it's going to matter to understand
what those words are,
and once again, they're not going to be
some kind of crazy words
that you only memorize
for a standardized test.
And this is an example of that,
I have a passage
of relevant words in context,
and this is going to be from
the new SAT writing section.
And the new SAT writing section,
as you see, we're in context here,
and this little four with
the circle around it,
this shows that, hey,
this part of the passage
is referring to question four.
And I'll look at this real fast.
As Kingman developed as a painter,
his works were often compared to paintings
by Chinese landscape artists dating back
to CE 960, a time when a strong tradition
of landscape paining
emerged in Chinese art.
Kingman however, and then
the default right here
is vacated from that tradition
in a number of ways.
Well, vacated once again,
isn't a crazy word, it's
a word that you will hear
in everyday language, in college
and in work, but it
sounds a little bit off.
And you look at the choices here,
evacuated, departed, retired,
once again, all words that you will see
in college, and you will see in life,
at least for this one,
and my job here isn't to
answer the SAT questions,
but hey, this feels like he departed
from the traditions.
So I would have gone with that.
But anyway, this isn't
about doing the questions,
but more seeing how these questions --
what they actually look like.
These aren't crazy words that you would
only just memorize for a test,
these are useful words to know in life,
and once again we have a context
of when we would use it.
We would use it maybe to
edit a passage like this.
So the other major themes of the new SAT,
command of evidence.
So we're going to see
in the writing, reading,
and math sections to be able to
look at either, it could be data,
and this could even be
in the reading section,
hey, what kind of data can help us
make different types of conclusions,
or even thinking about
how we might rewrite something based
on the data that's relevant,
and this is an example
of it right over here.
And once again, I'm not
gonna go into this question,
there's other videos we have
where we do example problems,
but this is interesting,
you're seeing kind
of data evidence, and this
isn't even the math section.
So this is another example
of something you might see
or you will see on the new SAT.
And the reason why that's important,
is because you will see
this throughout life.
It's not like reading
or writing is somehow
separated from data.
All of these things happen together
in the real world,
and it might not just be data evidence,
it could be looking at evidence,
an author's argument, so it could be
written evidence of some sort as well.
The essay, the optional essay
on the new SAT is going to be about
analyzing a source.
So looking at what's happening,
and analyzing where
kind of the conclusions
are coming from and we
can go into more depth
in future videos on that.
Now the math portion,
this is a big deal that the new SAT --
classically the SAT had
been associated with,
hey, maybe it's a little bit trickier
or things like that, but the new SAT
really is focused on the
things that you actually learn
in school.
So learn in school,
and it's even a subset of that.
It's kind of the most important subset
especially for being
college and life ready.
So the sections or the
types of problems you'll see
are the heart of algebra.
This is really the core of
algebra that really matters.
Then you're gonna see the
passport to advanced math,
and these are the skills that allow you
to have the knowledge
to get higher level math
that you will take in college.
So you're ready to take
those pre-calculus,
calculus, statistics
courses that you might see
in college, and then
there's problem solving
and data analysis.
Once again, these are real world types
of data analysis things,
things that you will see
throughout college and
in your entire life,
so it's focused on things
you learn in school,
and things that are going to matter
in college and life.
Now another big theme,
and this is across all the sections,
is real world contexts.
These aren't just tricky problems
in some type of vacuum,
these are going to be
things that you're going
to be seeing.
I know I keep repeating that,
but you see that theme
that they're not just kind of brain teaser
type things, these are things
that you will see as you go through
your college career.
Analysis in science and social studies.
So even though the sections
are formerly reading
and math and writing,
they're going to use those sections
in order to touch on important topics
in science and social studies,
so you're definitely going to see
a broader coverage of different types
of domains in the new SAT.
And this is one that I
found really interesting,
this notion of founding documents
and great global conversation
as being part of the SAT.
So it's a really, I
would say, good incentive
to get familiar with things
like to get familiar with things like the
Gandhi's Quit India speech,
or the Declaration of Independence,
or the Federalist Papers.
You're going to see this type of thing
in the new SAT in a reading passage
or to kind of make some
judgement about some things.
And then, the last bullet point here,
this is just kind of a high level point,
and this emphasizes that this new SAT
really is about what do you know,
not having to think about,
hey do I guess, do I not guess?
There's no penalty for wrong answers.
In the past, there was a
penalty for wrong answers,
but now there's no penalty.
So if you feel like you
have a sense of something,
or really even if you don't,
you should at least try
to answer every question
that you get to.
You shouldn't get into all the whole
gamesmanship of, okay, should I do it,
or should I not.
So hopefully this gives you a sense
of things, I have some
other questions here
that maybe make things a little bit more
tangible, this one right over here,
this is would be the passport
to advanced math right over here.
You have a non-linear system,
but this is really useful.
This is something that you will see
in school, especially
when you get to college,
and then they have data
analysis questions like this
which is very valuable as you, once again,
go into college, and
really almost any field
you go into, you're gonna have to do
data analysis or things like this.
So hopefully this gives you
an overview, and
encourages you to dive in,
and the best way, always,
to prepare for this,
is use the Khan Academy tools.
Take the practice test,
review the questions
that you get really wrong
or that you're not sure about,
and then do as much deliberate practice
as you need and the
system will personalize
to your needs so that you get
hopefully, the best use of your time.
Have fun.